I'm just looking for more information on how you're scored, so as you can see your pattern
is scored based on the number 10, out of 10 is your 1.
As you can see it's split up into 2 parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So from the number 4 you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern,
and then with that one any mistakes that you make, whether it's a double, say a double
or a couple, or a three or a four, you're actually scored based on the number 10.
If it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of 0.1, if it's a major mistake, you get minus
0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very very small thing, so say we're doing an outer block,
if it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower, or maybe it's a tiny bit
higher, that's a minor mistake, so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern, but you
forget and you say you do a reach hand strike instead, so that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1 for example, there's 20 steps, it's not
uncommon to have up to maybe 14-15 mistakes in the 20 patterns, or in the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to get a major mistake,
is to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon to say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes, so what
would that be?
So we'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the
square at the end.
So a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, but you turn to the right,
that would be a major mistake, so obviously we do want to try and avoid any of these major
mistakes.
So after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into 3 parts, so we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed, your rhythm is also a score
of 2, and your expression of energy is also scored out of 2 as well.
So we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, we're done.
It's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything that you do, it needs
to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch, but it has to be both
strong and fast to get high in that category.
The next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern, it's not
just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow rhythm.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of an aspect to it as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So what is expression of energy?
That's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern
as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong, your rhythm
is really great, but you're not shouting very loud.
Or you can kind of tell.
The judge will tell you.
The judge can kind of tell you're not really confident, you're a little bit nervous, so
that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So I'll just come around to this side.
So with this one, for colour belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a colour belt, you'll actually, your average, so where the judges actually
mark you from, it's actually from a 1.1.
So this is your average.
So.
If you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else, your score for 1, 2 and
3, it'll start from a 1.1.
So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power
and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt.
Generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3.
But let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So.
Expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to say, let's say a 1.0.
So with this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10, so let's see, and for presentation,
we had 1.7, 1, 2, 3, so you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes, you got a 3.7.
Let's see.
So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your
mistakes.
This is, with the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel, and each judge obviously
is very subjective, so from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes
or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So.
Say we did our.
Now, 15 mistakes, very small mistakes so if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.7.
We are, so we add these numbers at the, after the judges finish scoring.
So you would get 3.5.
Okay.
10.
for this pattern a 6.2 which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more
now about this number here so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow uh or above and you do
your patterns it's not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four
four to five so if you get a number between uh four and five out of ten for your pattern that's
actually uh generally considered pretty good so anything above that uh you can consider yourself
pretty good uh if you're a blackboard the average would say because um we're talking here about
the the higher presentation as an average anything from five to two sorry five to six
is actually considered
uh pretty pretty good and anything over a seven is actually considered almost world-class so
if you get a seven for any of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you
did an amazing job so we just went through our full-time scoring so just remember accuracy is
a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and
the two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was
uh i was judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe
he saw a couple more mistakes than i did and maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a
five point something another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we get
the three numbers and then we'd average that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys
so make sure you enjoy your competition and anytime i make sure obviously you
record down your numbers as well
practice reading
perfectly continue some minor errors yeah you can we cannot watch this time
because like we're simulating like a real judge do your own performance
yeah and then major errors and then right after the performance is power and speed
coordination of rhythm and an expression of energy from 0.5 to 2. yeah perfect okay are you ready
let's do this
so
so so
I don't know.